in Benin West Africa the Bessarabia
tribe has lived the same way for
hundreds of years one key to the tribe
sense of identity is ritual
scarification in this arduous bloody
process the scars left by cuts form
intricate designs the Besser rebe scar
the face to mark the start of childhood
and the abdomen to signify adulthood
here in the village of tacky sare
nada mangu is preparing to leave his
childhood behind soon slices in the skin
of his stomach will officially initiate
him into adulthood whenever my friends
and I are together always cry baby and
now I went to show you that iTunes
register the Bessarabia initiate young
men into adulthood every four years
mangu missed the last ceremony because
he was in Nigeria working on a farm the
ones who are already certified when they
see me now they don't except to society
the village blacksmith Madoff elix will
perform the scarification using scrap
metal and an ancient bellows feelings
will make a knife to use on mangu its
initiation day mangu fortifies himself
with millet porridge and his mother
offers a quick sip of homemade alcohol
why should I lie down like this yes as
his family was on mangu receives the
first cuts the process will take nearly
an hour in a nearby village preparations
are underway for the facial
scarification of a child
nacho filly according to best Arriba
custom once a child has been weaned from
his mother he is ready for scarification
Philippe's mother coos Anka tenpai
considers the tradition a vital step she
believes the ritual will please our
ancestors spirits and protect Philippe
from harm happy because he's only going
to cry I can console him Philippe's head
has been partially shaved so the
scarification can reach the very top of
his forehead by tradition the ceremony
must take place on flat ground beneath a
tree with the child resting on a bed of
fresh weeds
[Music]
the blacksmith begins cutting with the
village elders looking on the blacksmith
spends some 30 minutes
edging designs into the boy's face the
scarification is done though couse Anka
stayed with her son her husband couldn't
take it I went away I was afraid to see
my child leading to fight infection
couse Anka covers Philippe's wounds with
a salve made from the leaves of the
shade tree Philippe scars have initiated
him as a child of the Bessarabian
in the other village Mongoose ordeal is
nearly over his scarified peers arrived
- hey Liz the boy's partner the
ancestral spirits singing to celebrate
their friend
on his chest milk will be on doing
another would Oprah do me I told him it
went by enduring the pain of
scarification mangu has proved his
manhood and cemented his bond with the
community